every generation in my family has been
involved in dark misdeeds my name is
casey hammer and i'm about to reveal
the dark twisted secrets of the hammer
family army hammer's aunt vows to expose
bombshells in discovery plus his
upcoming series house of hammer
army's downfall started last year after
he was accused of rape and abuse by
several women allegations his attorney
denies
i am here
to
talk about
what happened in my relationship with
army hammer
now the docu-series is shedding light on
the claims against the actor
in the beginning i felt like this was
all perfect this was amazing
he would say things god you're so
perfect how could you be this beautiful
this smart so funny it's like you were
made for me
but then things changed i mean he said
i'm 100 a cannibal
i'm freaking out
yeah it's even getting into that rumor
then
you get a note that says i'm gonna bite
the [ __ ] out of you and he just like
acted mad
not just alleged x's the doc also
features one of army's relatives i've
let the hammers control me my whole life
it's time to stop
i refuse to be silenced his aunt casey
who's a producer on the series as well
compares the hammer dynasty to the roy
family on hbo's succession i'm stuck in
quicksand my family disappeared on the
outside we were a perfect family but
magnify succession a million times and
it was my family
if you believe about making deals with
the devil
the hammers are top of the totem pole
all three episodes of the series
premiere september 2nd on discovery plus
it's just generation to generation
the first look comes less than a month
after learning army got some a-list
support on his journey to sobriety last
month the source told e.t none other
than robert downey jr was helping army
through his recovery you grow and you
change that's so not part of
what you are anymore you know
robert has been a pillar in the sober
community in la and always has the best
intentions and really wants to help
people
meanwhile when it comes to army's family
they seem to be healing and staying busy
she's every perfect thing that i have in
my life she refers to elizabeth chambers
army's now estranged wife wafted shares
posts like these enjoying activities
with their two kids seven-year-old
harper and five-year-old ford
how many baby
we also know army's been spending time
in los angeles
and was even spotted out and about with
elizabeth and the kids in tow
back in february et learned army's main
priority is raising his kids alongside
elizabeth our source added they are
co-parenting really well and effectively
and he is trying really hard to get his
life back on track
you